The Joe Rogan Experience do you want to
hear some music sure
so I told you I was gonna play these
songs that I've haven't recorded or
released so this might be the only place
you could hear them okay but I think I'm
gonna record them
okay
[Music]
you tell me this is a dream but I'm
grinding my teeth and spilling my cup in
the backseat and pulling your hair you
drive too slow cause you don't care if
we get there
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with the Silence
from you
from you
[Music]
new guy kind of 90s rock
foreign
you want to hear another one yeah okay
New or Old whatever okay
okay whatever you want to play
[Music]
what did it cost
what did it cost
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
you're punching concrete
flesh and stone meat
beautiful body heart
running from open arms
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you want me to
[Music]
know what you paid
it in space
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
come and rest with
me now
[Music]
let my love
for you down
[Music]
if you are allow me to
do
[Music]
if you are
too
if you want me too
you want me too
foreign
[Music]
's over
for you and whoever wants to hear it
um
yeah it's weird because I only played
that for my husband and a friend of mine
so wow it's kind of
kind of scary I guess because they're
just little baby songs I just finished
so they might change I don't know it's
just
um
I don't know I try not to be too
precious about it like
um
that's vulnerable
you know like
uh so that's kind of scary
do you ever think it would have you have
who you would have been if you didn't
discover music oh yeah I would have been
living in Cleveland selling pizza and
spaghetti at my family's restaurant